so so for today I just kind of wanted to
go through so on our orientation day uh
back when we had the full committee
orientation the morning we met here in
the afternoon we we didn't really get
into a whole lot of detail of process
for division two so I kind of wanted to
just go through
the next six weeks process and I know I
I'll be honest this was somewhat focused
for our two new members and they're not
here so some of this might be refresher
for for for those returning which is all
of you but also for division two we have
a couple new members so just Mr chair
it's ultimately up to you how we proceed
but I'll
yeah so one question that came up
earlier was our deadline so we're
looking ahead and working back the last
day that we our office really needs for
division decisions to be made on House
Bill one and two is March 23rd and that
would give us enough time to turn it
around your package to present to the
full committee that following Monday so
March 23rd is a Thursday that following
Monday is when division two would
present its budget proposal to the full
committee so working backwards from then
you're talking a month and a week is
about what we have which will go quick
uh February is a short month
yeah but starting now you do have the
governor's recommended budget uh in
there you got the uh executive summary
the capital budget which we don't really
have to concern ourselves with uh you
heard yesterday's budget address you
heard this morning you had an hour close
to two hours with the governor's office
uh
did you want me to point out anything
specific in this like like I said we've
got all of our familiar members here so
this document should look like something
you've seen before as far as fiscal 22
actuals fiscal 23 adjusted authorized 24
25 proposed there's positions in this
document for each accounting unit how
many authorized positions there are so
this tier this big book I would
recommend you keep it in this room so as
the agencies start coming in tomorrow
this will be the working document that
we're we're using so when they come in
to present their budget if you want to
go through their entire department
they'll have a presentation handout I'm
sure but this is really the official
working document that we're making
when I say keep it here as long as you
have this with you on the days we're
working on that agency however you do
that you don't have to keep the big
books together you know here all the
time but when we get to so for instance
tomorrow morning
um ccsnh and usnh are coming in to
present their Governor's recommended
budget uh they have one line in here so
they're easy and then in the afternoon
Lottery and police standards are coming
in so these are you know the accounting
units they'll be working from when
they're talking about the governor's
recommended budget so this is the
the working document if you will
um
it should be right on the very front
page
the very first page of your binder
should have an index hopefully
alphabetized by agency with the page
yep
yep so they're they're around like page
1209 and 1212 if I remember correctly
yeah so when they come in tomorrow they
don't have many accounting units
compared to doe dot safety so those
should be easier budgets which is kind
of the idea for why we're scheduling
them first hopefully there won't be much
work for those but you'll hear from them
tomorrow
mic up here some of the smaller budgets
they're not they're not probably not
going to come back
so this is kind of it
right and then we can vote them somewhat
sometime later but we're not going to
have standards in twice
so so so real quickly uh
so ccsnh usnh Lottery police standards
tomorrow next Tuesday dot the following
Tuesday doe and that following Wednesday
safety and fishing game so by March 1st
you'll have had all of our agencies in
at least once
uh some of them you won't have to have
back the one problem is we don't have
House Bill 2 and probably won't during
most of those presentations so we may
have to invite some folks back for House
Bill 2 related for cleanup for cleanup
yeah education for instance I just feel
like that's definitely going to take up
a lot of time on the back end of our
schedule uh
but as we're going so say even tomorrow
if police standards come in comes in
with oh you know we notice this budget
error and we need to make a correction
we ask the committee to you could vote
on that tomorrow you know you could make
that recommendation everything this
division does is simply a recommendation
for the full committee's official vote
so as you're going along you can make
motions you can do it based off of the
document provided by the agency it can
be uh you know just as long as the
motion is clear you know uh you know
reduce a class line by X dollars Mickey
do you got that yeah I got that and I'm
gonna track everything and that's why I
handed these documents we'll go over
here shortly and I'll keep a running tab
of all of our tentative decisions
throughout the the next six weeks until
we get to March 23rd when you'll make a
final overall vote based on the
everything I've compiled for you and
then we'll take it across the the hall
they're going to come in and present
their Governor's recommended budget we
haven't heard from either of those two
agencies at all yet so they'll tell you
a little about about what they do
lottery for instance doesn't have any
general funds you know they're they're
self-funded their net profits go to the
education trust fund their budget's
usually pretty easy unless they have any
technical Corrections they need to make
that sort of thing police standards is
generally funded
um and they'll talk to you about what
what they're planning to do for the next
two years if if there's no changes that
their agencies looking to make and you
feel well that's a we don't have to do
anything more of them you can
tentatively accept their budget or you
can wait and we can do it later it's not
you know so that you may not be ready to
make a final decision because we don't
know things like revenues yeah you know
police standards is budgets probably not
going to decide a whole lot of this
division's overall work you know they're
I think it's like a five and a half
million dollar budget
um considering we're going to be in the
billions when we're talking about the
education trust fund in total so some of
those smaller agencies you probably
could be okay with
um if if nothing jumps out to to you as
as things you want to look further into
but then again House Bill 2 police
standards may have something in House
Bill too a new program so we might need
to invite them back later
yep
okay
but
Mickey when do you know when we're gonna
start getting revenues when we will know
how much money
the hope is so house Ways and Means is
working on that now the hope is by
around the beginning of March that first
week of March they'll have a resolution
ready to go and we can our office can
build that into the governor's
recommended budget so update his Revenue
estimates with Ways and Means revenues
and see where we are big picture and
then you'll know how much you have
either to spend or not spend or
depending on what those revenues are as
they differ from the governors so
hopefully I think we are planning on
March 1st as our tentative date our
hopeful date
it's so just to make sure I understand
this correctly
you know for now we're gonna operate
based on the Assumption of the revenue
that we have in the governor's budget
and we'll wait for the you know
appropriate guidance from the ways and
its means once we get it and that may
drive us to re-examine some of the
earlier
temporary decisions we made but we may
very well not need to so we are
retaining the flexibility dealing with
as much as we can ahead of time
I appreciate it thank you
so
I I've handed out a little packet for
everybody just to kind of show you the
example of the working documents that
I'm going to try to keep everyone up
with for the next several weeks so these
are essentially our starting point so
the first uh spreadsheet would would
capture everything I could call this
like our whole universe like anything
that's brought to this committee's
attention from the agencies that they
would like you to consider uh as well as
all the bills that we've got so if you
look down on the bottom you can see the
five bills that we've already retained
to this point and then yesterday nine
new bills were referred to finance so
I've tried to track those just so we
don't let anything slip through the
cracks really that upper section you see
I've kind of got some place holders for
safety fishing and transportation
education as the agencies start coming
in and we hear their new requests I'll
add those on here so you'll we'll have a
sheet to remember everything that the
agencies are looking to have you
consider
it doesn't matter yeah so the the top is
really like budget changes the agencies
are asking for and you see it's blank
now because we haven't heard from them
yet and then the next section down is
just bills that we do know of that are
in this committee
foreign
that first subset down below under
retained most of them are the school
building Aid
yeah oh yeah you may have a hole punch
through retained I'm sorry so yeah that
first subset is the retain bills that
we've already voted on and then the
pending is the new ones that will have
uh educate yeah and Mickey
um these are pretty much all came out of
Education
um but why are they general fund as a
post-education
just fun so under current law the
education trust fund only pays for
adequacy Charter Schools uh efas School
building Aid tuition Transportation a
special education Aid these costs are
not relative to those programs it's
certainly in you know this committee
could open the education trust fund
usage to pay for other things but I have
them defaulted to education or a general
fund for now
put
sorry building Aid is uh education trust
fund currently yes
you can you can add more education trust
and the governor did add I believe 75
million dollars already so the budget
you had before you already has an
uh I mean it could be it could be 75
total and this is where getting House
Bill 2 will be helpful I know we have a
line item for building Aid in the budget
I haven't analyzed that fully yet but I
think 75 it could be 75 total including
tail
yeah no that could be yeah so 75 total
but that is education trust fund
uh yeah plus or minus
just to clarify
um if we decide to switch the hygiene
product in schools from general fund to
education trust fund that would require
an hb2 section
or not it would so RSA 198 39 I think it
is explicitly States the uses of the
education trust fund if the committee
wanted to explore adding more programs
to that or uses we would have to amend
that in hospital too to make it
permissible but certainly that's within
the purview of this committee but
without an hp2 amendment this would have
to be general fund right now yeah I mean
we could yeah to to do it properly you'd
let me ask a macro question as we look
at this and we this gets totaled up I
mean we're not going to do all these but
just just for conversation
down at the bottom here it's 148 million
dollars
do we have to in order to approve these
do we have to debit 148 million dollars
somewhere else
it's a good question and I will tell you
that these were essentially fiscal note
um uh no I'm I'm not questioning the
dollars yeah well how do we balance it
in a macro so there's there's two ways
to look at that one and the governor had
presented that both the general fund and
the education trust fund still have
remaining balances left over even after
his proposals so you could just
appropriate and it would just reduce the
amount that's left over at the end of
the biennium or uh yeah you you would do
offsets so you would do a reduction
somewhere add this so it's a net zero
that's up to the committee
didn't he also indicated at least part
of his budget was already considering
certain of the FN bills I mean I know he
specifically talked about the 3.1
percent for Medicaid being based on a
bill that will be an FN but that's
already in the budget so some of this
may already be in the governor's budget
that's a great point so that's what I
was saying these these estimates here
are based on current law if the governor
funded one of these programs or a
portion of for instance building a we
know there's new money in there for
building Aid so these estimates here
would be something less than that
because the governor already funded some
of it and these would just be and so as
we get hone in on what you're looking to
do I would have more precise numbers
based on really the incremental change
from this document because that's what
we don't have to take the governor's
budget
line by well by line by line we really
need to but I mean we don't have to
adopt everything the governor says so if
we for example if we know there's a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
Surplus in the trust then if there are
things here that we choose to want to
fund then we can draw down from that and
then we'd have um we could kind of
balance that
but we don't know how much money we have
overall yet we we have the governor's
Surplus statements so that shows us the
general fund big picture and the
education trust big picture based on his
spending his revenues has this much left
over once you have new revenues
obviously that picture changes right and
then we'll we'll adjust that for you
then you'll know okay once we've
Incorporated the house revenues now that
hundred and what was it 170 million or
whatever the leftover for Education
trust fund
or 140 no that's not it 148 maybe that
is only going to be like 48 because you
had education Trust on Revenue estimates
100 million dollars less than the
governor for instance so
big picture uh it's the revenues from
Ways and Means will drive uh some of the
bigger decisions
correct
so I'm looking at the hb521 placement
for episode of treatment payments uh the
fiscal note is indeterminable
that one is just the build that
substitutes
the source of funds from the local
school district to the you know State I
would agree that it's almost impossible
to project forward accurately because
it's special education but I would have
expected the Department of Education at
least to give me a retroactive you know
analysis of had we had this deal in this
biennium this is how many of those would
have fallen to us is that something we
can request of them to help us better
understand the potential impact because
we will have to put a number on it
that's a good question so we never got
any information from the Department on
that bill so there's no fiscal note
attached to that at this point the
reason I had suggested that I get called
into this committee is that court
ordered placement line item is
essentially an open warrant so whatever
those costs are to the state whether
it's in the budget or not we have to pay
so when we do a work session on that
bill we'll make sure someone from
special education from the Department is
here and hopefully can provide some
ranges at least of what the cost could
be
indeed but having historical data on
what it has been in the past is valuable
in helping us understand what we may
what our exposure is and what we may
have left and the department can give
you like a 10-year range because they've
been collecting it over years and then
the any money left in cat aid used to
have to go into this fund I don't know
is it still the same way it it is but
cat AIDS usually yeah it's not fully
funded so there I don't think there's
been yeah but it would lapse to that
so so this first page here would be I'm
going to capture everything that I think
you you should want to consider that's
presented to you essentially so the next
page is pretty blank too so this is
going to be where I populate the house
bill two sections that are assigned to
this division it's probably going to be
more than the cells that I have
allocated so and then
if there's any new ideas that this
committee proposes that's not already
in-house built to something brand new
I'll list those at the bottom this will
make sure that this division has a
recommendation of everything in hose
build too before it leaves here we've
done our work so you may make no changes
to something the governor proposes and
we would say except you know you're
going to accept that as it is uh if
there are amendments and this this is
really for the new members
um
they come through me I'd be glad to help
assist in drafting amendments that way I
can keep track of everything make sure
the division's got everything we need
help help with the any specifics of the
language that you're looking to do any
proposals
um so that's that'll be where we Track
House Bill 2 and then the next document
will be where I tracked any approved
changes to anything that affects funding
so that very first page was here's
everything that's presented to you and
then this page will be okay these are
the some of the tentative decisions
you've made and I'll start putting them
on here just so you remember oh yeah we
did vote for that or this will be our
tracking document of stuff we've done
the final thing attached to this was
just our uh our one from two years ago
just as an example so you can kind of
see what this might look like
when we're done so this was uh the final
division two recommendations from the
22-23 budget
you can you can kind of see what it
looks like once we start getting the
yes
I I just want to put out on the table
it seems to me there's several several
ways that can go
obviously I'd like to see it in the
educational trust fund if it remains
but is that something that we need to
continue to do and if we do I have to
agree with uh representative Edwards
that it is a 28-day violation and we
should Pony up I think his Pony up
numbers are way high
and I don't see paying for it in arrears
so my thought is it it should be in here
because you you all went through quite a
procedure to get it I was not here I was
on vacation that term
um so it passed and was part of the
budget
so I think it should stay but I think we
should re take
amend Edward's bill
I'm asking a question as much making a
statement we take Edward's Bill and
amend it to a lower dollar amount and
get rid of the past history is that
something we do as an amendment to his
bill or do we introduce a new hp2
section
since uh since you are looking to have
money attached to it I think we would
put in House Bill too so we would
estimate so so you're suggesting an
amendment to say rather than twelve
dollars is three dollars three dollars
so we would extrapolate out how much do
we think three dollars per would be and
then we could do an appropriation along
with that to the Department of Education
to pay these reimbursements and that
would be house bill 2. only because it
has spending in it I wouldn't want to
send it along in a separate bill because
now we we have the budget and then we'd
have a separate bill with money I agree
I'm just asking a question so when we
get to Doe's budget that could be a
house bill 2 amendment that we we could
have drafted and consider so it would
basically be a division two Amendment
and the Edwards bill will consider in
the in the fall when we do pending and
when we do retain bills since we did do
a vote to retain that already so we
don't have to revisit that when we do a
retain bill this fall you could itl it
then saying we took care of everything
yep
go ahead Murray
with that thought that's going to be the
case from any of these right so School
building aid for instance right we're
not going to pass any of these three
School building Aid bills you're going
to have a school building Aid policy
in-house Bill too and we're going to
turn around and probably you'll look to
it all these in the fall too same idea
there's going to be a few of those that
are going to be the ones coming to us on
the bottom here the ones that we just
got yesterday would be the same thing
okay
okay on retain bill you can take that
and work on it anytime
up until what November whatever it is
yeah I think it's usually October report
I mean division two they'll probably
just be one executive session as a full
committee sometime close to that report
deadline but we'll have you know the
committee commute anytime I think they
usually don't pay mileage in like July
or something like that but any other
time in the late summer you know we
could meet on those it probably would
take one day unless you really wanted to
dive into a subject matter and have
multiple work sessions but chances are I
think we'll have hit it all on hp2 I
think so too
here we go ahead you know on this uh HP
129 it seems to me that I don't remember
should people that spoke for a
representative evidence it seemed to me
that they were more in line with
eliminating the mandate
and uh
they said things work really well until
like I said I wasn't here when this
became
a mandate uh so I I don't know what the
hearings were like or anything else so
I'm assuming it's something we need we
as a body at that time thought it was
appropriate
inal ceiling stuff like that
and I can see that happening if they
don't have any skin in the game
that they don't have to pay for them you
know they're just in the restaurants and
that's and that's not me that's the two
people that spoke
and
it's about demanding
it might have worked well for them but
not necessarily for the girls right and
there are schools that were not
providing the products and there were
girls that were missing a week of school
a month because they can't afford the
products there was also um you know I
think we could have a discussion around
the language that it has to be in the
bathroom because some of the schools
were saying well you can go to the PE
teacher you can go to the nurse but that
there was a for some a stigma attached
to that that you know it was
embarrassing for the girls to do that it
was kind of in line with the free and
reduced lunch where you hadn't you had
like your hand stamped or something or
you had a different colored tab so
everybody knew that you had free and
reduced lunch and high school kids
weren't doing that because they were
embarrassed so this is a way of trying
to provide a mechanism that allowed
girls to to go through you know to get
what they needed without the
embarrassment about it
um
you oh I'm sorry yeah the level of
poverty would blow your mind in some
places it's just it goes beyond the pale
last year
Nashville School District I think the
figures
so school districts haven't been
invested they've had to invest what it
is is they had to put dispensers into
many of the breasts we didn't say that
for a while in the war just that they
have to be completely available to teach
young women and so um
it has been read or interpreted that it
has to be dispensers and that's been the
cost so I don't know if I'm going to
amend it to ease the restrictions
apparently that they just have to be
available in multiple places of the
schools choosing that there will be no
Stigma attached to obtaining a female
product
if we wanted to do something like that
but there has been a cost to school I'm
absolutely shot but I've been query the
school district since Community evidence
discussions and there has been an
expense that it's already been incurred
so they have spent the money they have
they are carrying this bill out so
people have already thought well when I
mentioned the cost of them
I've been in this division before I just
know the final man graduated eighth
grade he had eight children
and my sisters were all set
that was a while ago there was no
freedom to be response either
I didn't talk to you about getting in
if if I may just I I look back at the
the emails uh that we received on that
particular bill we got an email from
somebody who thought that we were trying
to remove the you know policy and that
was not the case but uh when uh
representative Edwards replied uh he did
point out that the Auburn Village School
principal who testified was bothered by
the state mandate and the enormous waste
and extra cost it has added so
the point is that
if it is the will of the committee to
not Tinker with a policy it may behoove
the committee to just maybe clarify the
language a little to eliminate that
perception of you know the need for a
dispenser in the bathroom that seems to
be the huge you know if that's the right
policy I you know I I all I'm you know
but it's
spouse right now well but if we change
the amount
you know we may I mean if we are going
to reduce the appropriation from what
was suggested originally we may have a
ability to make it clear what that is
supposed to cover and what the Mandate
really says you know especially since
all we are talking about is clarifying
which I'm hearing people say that it was
a misunderstanding of what the Mandate
really was you know I'm it's not my
intent to change the legislature in the
legislatures you know mandate on that
but
yeah
the project process and we're getting
sidetracked no we're gonna have to make
a decision on this
yeah this is in our lap
we're not getting sidetracked I said
when I open it up I'm going to jump in
the weeds because I've been thinking
about this okay
and I just wanted to get
thoughts okay Mary
schools already pay for paper towels and
toilet paper and soap and soap
dispensers so there is a line somewhere
in the school budget for this stuff
yeah and
again around the stigma thing if
I don't know how we could possibly do
that but I mean it's like why isn't that
folded into that line instead of being
singled out because again that's draws
more attention perhaps than what some
people would like but I don't know you
know this money that I think I think we
owe the the school something if we're
asking them to do this but having it
folded into what would we eventually be
considered normally supplied materials
for a bathroom I mean you don't go into
any public bathroom and bring your own
toilet paper you know it's just provided
and most bathrooms now provide hygiene
huh
okay
right no that's that's absolutely right
so but mostly even you know restaurants
and stuff there's a drawer in those
restrooms that provide all this material
usually at least the restaurants I go
line of things that schools need to
provide well I've got an amendment that
uh
was provided to me almost two days later
that changed the wording of the first
line that just said it'd make it
available and take the bathroom take the
whatever it's called no no no it says in
the bathroom right or not bad I can't
think of the language but it
specifically says this is where it's got
to be
and this amendment uh
took that language out and just said
available so I'll bring that with me
when I when we get some serious about
this so this is a good example so if if
you have an amendment that you'd like to
propose to the committee you can work
with me and I can draft something so it
could be changing the amount of the
reimbursement it could be changing the
mandate to a you should do this thing
whatever if there's something on one of
these issues
um you would like to propose to the
committee for consideration just reach
out to me and I can help draft an
amendment for you and then we'll have a
document to you know vote on or uh you
know as we get to that subject matter
because all these will be carried on
here which means they're always up for
sub subject to an amendment or debate or
or a motion or whatever so
um
because right now if we did nothing with
that but retain it
uh the current policy would be in effect
and that is whatever the language is and
it's it's up to the school to pay for it
correct
and I will point out because I I make
mistakes
on that line if you look at fiscal uh 25
I think that's 600 and that's supposed
to be 630 000 not 6.3 million so I have
so it's not that much money oh okay so
it just just saved you six million
dollars okay what up the top so what are
we going to spend there I think one I
think this is one too many zeros there
yeah so there should be 630 000 I
believe if I remember correctly from the
fiscal note the language in question I
looked up the Bailey's uh available at
no cost in all gender neutral bathrooms
and bathrooms designated for females
located in public middle and high
so that's essentially what I wanted to
go through today was kind of big picture
process we will have to talk about what
days we're meeting I did build out a
tentative schedule and actually have
agencies booked through March 1st after
that nothing is scheduled for for
division two officially yet we're gonna
have session days that will interfere
with ability to do work town meeting day
is in there I don't know if that's a day
that we I'm out that day so that that'd
be a day that at the very most you would
maybe hear from somebody with no
intention of voting if all your members
aren't going to be here potentially
still use the data to hear a
presentation or uh and then we're gonna
have a house bill one and two public
hearing at some point so we may lose a
sometimes it's happened that we do a
public meeting in different parts of the
state to get different things um I don't
recall that Weiler did not do that the
last round
do we we did it virtually okay have you
heard anything about going around the
state yet I haven't heard anything uh
yeah two years ago we did Zoom public
hearings actually we had folks
registering and did a zoom public
hearing uh four years ago I carry in
Laconia I think we we've done we did
here
Dairy and Laconia we've done Dairy
Laconia I'm trying to remember we've
done Nashville before we've done
Whitefield before
possibly possibly so but I have I
haven't heard either a date or uh if
there's going to be any traveling public
hearings I don't know
okay
yeah that's where I learned fate with
bank
and one thing you heard a lot today was
education funding that was a big thing
so that's going to be a big lift
potentially for this division depending
on how much work you want to do in that
area the governor's budget is going to
come out we get House Bill too that's I
believe going to have 24 or 25 and
possibly out years different formulas so
the department will come in and give us
a briefing on that hopefully walk us
through the changes
um in the law and what that means on a
Town by Town level
we'll have yeah they'll have a
spreadsheet
um hopefully they should and a town by
Town showing current law versus proposed
so you can kind of see the town by Town
estimated impact uh and then as you get
into different proposals changing either
some of the amounts or changing it
whatever you look to do just keep in
mind that could take me and the
department it's not quick to turn that
stuff around you know it's really a
quality control thing we just want to
make sure we're not doing stuff too
quick and end up with errors so
um we get into I think the governor
referred to spreadsheet Wars today uh
where you know we'll we'll come up with
spreadsheets for another a new Amendment
a proposal and everyone will look to see
their town and how they did and we'll
try to keep up with that as much as
possible
but it's hard for us to turn around
super quickly multiple times throughout
the process but just want to throw that
um
I hope so we've requested a fiscal note
even on the bill is introduced I know it
was amended uh I think there was an
amendment on that bill
um
right right uh so instead of a new
Department was that the one yeah it'd be
a division within doe so no we haven't
we haven't received any uh
analysis from the Department so out of
those nine bills I've identified five
that I think we possibly could do
Tuesday morning
retain because they're definitely going
to be House Bill 2 budget items and
that's 419 420
560.
and 638 638 you might actually be able
to just pass but I think because we are
touching dead funding formula we'll
probably want to retain that one too so
if we retain all those we know those are
going to be
House Bill 2 budget issues the other
four bills 364 521 620 and 626 I think
we're going to need the department of
education's experts to come in just to
explain what's going on and then the
committee could decide what you want to
do with those if you want to pass them
uh 620 and 626 would probably be budget
items
364 and 521 could possibly pass
separately without having to amend the
budget depending on what we hear
potentially
that's on the 28th when we we do have
the department schedule for an entire
day so we'll hear from them for their
operating budget to kind of go through
it's just
yeah yeah so they'll they'll um my guess
is two hours in the morning we'll go
through all of this and then three hours
in the afternoon will be efas and
funding and uh including Charters and
school building Aid is what I'm
envisioning those education trust fund
Aid programs will probably take up most
of the time and hopefully we have host
Bill too by then that would make things
easier that they could kind of walk
through the changes in House Bill 2 and
the spreadsheets but even without House
Bill 2 it'll still be valuable to hear
from them and kind of see the numbers
foreign
I have a quick thought on 129 but I
didn't want to break the flow if we were
going in a different direction
one of the bills that I was a co-sponsor
on was a bill that would have provided
hygiene products to inmates and in order
to avoid any confusion and to avoid
political controversy over gender
language to build that bill used the
language of you know inmates who
menstruate
uh obviously I'm not really
you know hugely invested in changing the
language in a similar manner but I did
want to share that as a possibility if
anybody wants to file amendments here to
consider you know ways in which uh you
know we avoid the whole
definition questions around those topics
you know
and so on and so forth so no but the
point is you know students who
menstruate you know
would be a better language that would
try to walk us out of that Minefield and
it's exactly what the point is you know
if you menstruate you need hygiene
products if you don't you don't I don't
want to know anything else you know
right
um
so
it will see that so you won't you won't
see it for lottery because they don't
have it
um but certainly safety is the is one
that has a lot of different funding
sources so at the end of each accounting
unit so just to give everyone a
refresher so if we look at Lottery there
so it starts halfway down the page there
with 2028
Lottery division that's an accounting
unit so this accounting unit Lottery
basically has one accounting unit for
their entire budget continues on to the
next page
and then if you look at the kind of the
very bottom it's estimated source of
funds for this accounting unit
and most of it is sweepstakes funds
that's really all they have for 24 and
25 which is their Lottery fund so they
collect Lottery revenues net their
expenses against that remit the
difference to the education trust fund
so this is a pretty simple budget that's
kind of why we kind of do them usually
at the beginning there's no General
funds here
um
foreign
so yeah the accounting unit expenditure
class lines adds up to and I'll just use
the fiscal 22 actual line I've got 13
259 841 and then if you and then if you
look at the total sources of funds it's
13 259 841. hopefully those all balance
everywhere if those don't balance
right yeah and then if you flip over
because I'll point this out this is
what's great about this version of the
budget future versions don't have this
is you have the number of authorized
positions in each accounting unit so on
the on page 1211 you'll see that there's
82 permanent classified positions
currently and four unclassifieds but if
you jump ahead you can see their
complement goes up to 89 uh unclassified
positions so when the department when
Lottery comes in tomorrow
you'd say oh you have seven new
positions so they'll tell you about
those
a lot lottery for the most part is
usually if they have some technical
Corrections they maybe put money in the
wrong class line and they want you to
switch it or you know there's been some
new offerings in the last few years
Mobile gaming sports betting Kino for
instance so they have added some
positions relative to overseeing those
programs that we've done in the budget
uh I'm not sure what these seven
represent off the top of my head it
could be
yeah I'm not sure so that's something
we'll hear from tomorrow we'll hear from
Tomorrow yep and again House Bill 2 has
been something Lottery has had over the
years and I just don't really know what
is in there for for them for House Bill
2. uh Charlie McIntyre the director may
yeah Charlie will talk about the revenue
estimate how much he thinks he's going
to give to the education trust fund and
his budget is basically what he needs to
yep oh yeah it could be relative to that
charitable gaming is is is growing could
so yeah a lot so several probably at
least three budgets ago now racing and
charitable gaming commission merged with
Lottery
so
um charitable gaming is part of the
foreign
yes that's for that the administrative
and standards accounting unit 8980 they
have multiple accounting units at police
standards so if you flip the next page
you'll see the accounting unit for the
police crisis intervention training so
this was something that was a bill last
year that appropriated money you can see
that 1.1 million and the governor
appears to be uh extending that into the
next two years so director skippa can
talk about that program tomorrow
uh and you can
yeah
and then uh continuing on they have a
separate accounting unit specific to
their training so on page one two one
five accounting unit 6639 so they've got
the two major accounting units the
administration and standards and the law
enforcement training as far as their
normal routine operating budget and you
can see their positions there so so just
to point out so when you look at the
bottom of page 1215 you see they're
currently have 14 positions and now
they're the governor's budget is 15. so
I expect director skippa would speak to
oh this budget includes a new position
that's doing this and if not that would
be a good question you could ask oh I
see your position count goes up what's
the new position quick
um quick question about the formatting
of the Excel document
I'm always looking for ways to you know
throw a pivot table here and there and
this seems to be a format that would
make that very uh difficult if not
impossible
is this something that we could maybe
work with the governor's budget people
going forward so that the electronic
version of this is something that we can
slice and dice a bit more easily right
now this becomes basically a just one
big that I cannot really
easily aggregate in different ways and
compare stuff and if you do you have the
Excel version of this
it is posted online it is clunky it is
like you described it is kind of a big
sheet of just data
um there there are a couple methods to
filter out
that makes it a little bit more user
friendly but it hasn't been something
we've delved in a whole lot and it would
take admin Services Bureau of financial
reporting to I'm not asking for this
cycle frankly I understand that this is
what we get right now the work of
redoing this to feed the requirement
would be ridiculous but you know
so those are the two uh
State departments if you will or
agencies that we have tomorrow and then
we also have U.S and H and ccsnh which
just get their block appropriation from
the state so each of their they are in
this operating budget but they just have
one line and uh they'll speak to what
that state support would mean and if
there is any that
between what the governor gave them and
what they were asking for in their
agency budget request you'll hear about
that tomorrow too
so fishing game starts on page 561 but
they also have a separate Surplus
statement for the fish and game fund
that is almost better to just know the
big picture of the state of their uh
their because they are a self-funded
Agency for the most part so if you have
your um executive summary that green
folder from the the front there on page
31 of that document you'll see the fish
and game Surplus statement
and they are in much better condition
than they were six or so years ago for
sure
so if you look if you look on this
Surplus here on page 31
it breaks out their unrestricted
revenues their license fees
predominantly around 13.3 million
dollars it's estimated 13.4 moving
forward you can see the general fund
support
that the governor is proposing 1 million
and 24 and one and a half million and
25.
and then if you look at their
Appropriations in the next section down
15.9 million and 23 16.3 16.2
um the the governor did budget the pay
raise because those would apply to the
Fish and Game fund would cover the fish
and game employees for that and then
going down you'll see that they are
running
a negative current year balance so they
are pulling from their fund balance to
to be sustainable each each year so on
that current year balance line You'll
see they've got a negative result there
currently if you're looking for fiscal
22 ended 9.9 million dollars at the very
bottom the Gap adjusted balance is going
down to 7 million by the end of this
upcoming biennium so they are they do
have money in the bank but as you can
see this Governor's recommended budget
is chipping away at that balance each
year
foreign
so they're coming in on the first March
1st and we can ask them about that I
think there is a bill that mandates that
they do that by 25. yeah and I think
they're phasing in renewals first and
then initials so you can ask them how
that's going I think they've said that
Manpower is more the issue than than
money but they can speak more to that
when when you have them and if you want
so those five are essentially or I don't
want to say easier but as far as uh you
know fishing game is usually pretty easy
you just decide on your general fund
support
um if you choose to do any
ccsnation usnh are difficult from a
dollar
perspective because you're in the
millions you're talking a lot of money
you know when you're making changes
there but it is just one line item no
Personnel you don't deal with positions
with those two entities and fishing uh
police standards and Lottery tend to be
on the easier end for division two just
because the the agencies are small
uh doe Dot and safety is the bigger
workload
I think I think from a revenue point of
view I think revenues were down a little
bit because travel was down I think yeah
and as far as the highway fund
I mean they've had vacancy issues just
like a lot of State departments have so
there's been a lot of money not being
spent from the highway fund because they
haven't had the person all the manpower
to to spend it so they've lapsed Dot and
safety have lapped quite a bit of money
back into the highway fund from budgeted
amounts so they closed fiscal 22 with a
significant
balance ending balance and the general
fund if you recall we did send 50
million I believe of General funds to
prop up the highway fund last budget as
well as I think they used some federal
funds to uh support Highway funded
operations too to take the burden off
the highway fund so that helped the last
budget I think the Surplus statement so
I can jump real quick to the the highway
fund also has a surplus statement in
this document it's on page 30 where we
so here you'll see the the two major
sources of revenue which is our road
toll and motor vehicle fees so licensing
registrations
minus the department of safety and I
think they had testified to that or
presented this when they were in a week
or so ago DMV predominantly in their
Road tool Bureau
cover the costs that they have to
administer the collection of those
revenues so they keep that and then
remit the uh the net to the highway fund
and that's that total editions line you
see here
and then uh Department of Transportation
Department of Safety and the judicial
branch all get Appropriations from the
highway fund if you look fiscal 22
actual the Gap adjusted balance was over
100 million dollars
but if you look ahead of what the
governor's recommended budget
supports it ends at only 13 million
dollars so you can see each year is
running a deficit balance similar to uh
fish and game fund not quite as or fish
and game funds not quite as dramatic as
this and when the department comes in
they can testify to well what's included
in the governor's recommended budget
what are we doing what does that include
funding usually equipment winter
maintenance Highway Maintenance those
are the big areas but they'll speak to
that when they come in on
the with a the 21st Tuesday this coming
it's a good question for them I will
just remind you that's the turnpike
system so the toll collections wouldn't
impact the highway fund at all the
turnpike is a separate fund
from toll revenues to fund just those
Lane miles that are designated as the
turnpike system so when we're talking
Highway fund we're talking about State
roadways that are not the turnpike fund
uh but they'll speak to the specifics of
um
goodness
so as far as the highway fund and Fish
and Game fund similar to General and
education Ways and Means we'll do those
revenues as well so when we get our
resolution from from ways and means I'll
plug in those numbers to these Surplus
statements and it'll give you an updated
picture where you're starting
yeah Our Hope was by one March but we'll
see yeah yeah we'll we'll see how I'm
not sure how how quickly it'll come out
we're hope we're hoping for sooner than
later because that helps us committee
out
uh
and then any bills too that are flying
around that impact revenues will also
update the Surplus statements based on
those hopefully we capture those into
the budget package and they're not
separate and the other thing I will
point out is
um fiscal committee has a winter
maintenance item uh this meeting that
the department needs to draw from
Surplus to prop up their winter
maintenance budget for this year I think
it's around three and a half million
dollars so if that passes fiscal and GNC
when we update I'll update the Surplus
statement that you're working off of so
that 13.3 may go to 9.5 right off the
bat you know
issue
I think fiscal will hear fiscal will
hear their their testimony if if they
fast on Friday but the letter does does
detail the rates that they're paying to
correct
and and my guess is when they present
their budget Tuesday
um the governor probably address one way
or another the contracted rates that
they are able to pay for winter
maintenance so I think they'll speak to
uh so Highway funds Surplus statements
on page 30 of that executive summary
and while representative Buco is looking
for it
I'm really concerned that we are going
from an actual at the end of 22 over 111
to a recommended of 13.1 by the end of
25 I mean that's literally burning
through 100 million dollars of surplus
then what how is that sustainable so
that that's been a question for well
over a decade with the highway fund
there's been a lot of what have been
referred to as one-time fixes to prop up
the highway fund either a temporary
Revenue change a transfer from General
funds uh so so the department will speak
to that too on Tuesday but that they've
that's always been an issue because some
of the traditional Road tools
specifically for Highway fund revenue is
is stagnant or decreasing at best so
whereas most of the costs from Highway
funds are people and those costs
inherently increase over time so so that
formula has has been an issue for a long
time
foreign
yeah and I think
without seeing House Bill 2 it's hard
for me to say specifically what's
happening there
um I think what the phases are are the
different years I think you know so
looking this biennium and then and
things will change starting in fiscal 25
fiscal 26 so I think when we see House
Bill 2 we'll see that outline better and
when we hear from the Department they'll
walk us through that
um
yeah
the base amount is going to be increased
the free and reduced differentiated will
be increased I think the stabilization
Grant as we know it is going away but
will be replaced with a new hold
harmless
right
everyone's
very cute
they kept everything in two thousand
nights yeah but we've lost 250 kids at
least we lost a town Middleton and we're
still getting the same amount of
stabilization as we got in yeah because
it's fixed by dollars not by 2012 when
that number was calculated that hard
dollar amount has been the same amount
that you're getting today
you know and I'm getting you know I
wow
my superintendent will take the money
but matter of fact we're paying the same
you know we're our budget is increasing
and our our population is deep well this
this year remember seven about seven
ninety we lost 44 student texture
so and you know and that's
ridiculous and 143 students did not make
out or parents did not make out the free
and reduced form now that's what almost
300 000 which is part of what we need to
address but that's what we need to we
need to look at my understanding of what
the governor wants to do with the
stabilization is to
at some point you know give them 10
years to adjust with at least a few
years where there will be no downside
but with a clear visibility of a
downslope where they are expected to
understand that they need to plan
accordingly because those hard numbers
are based on number of kids that they
haven't had for a long time and it gives
them a fair warning than a gentle slope
and you know it will have to be
middle class which I I don't think the
intent is to do that at all I think the
intent is to basically adjust the
funding till it is Equitable with every
other town in the state and basically
remove this temporary additional benefit
that they are getting because of that
but to you know make it equally fair
with everybody that's again my
understanding of the intent of that we
haven't really read hb2 That's based on
a presentation oh I'm aware of the
history
right I think so so that one thing I
will say does Tuesday Morning work for
an egg uh work session on some of those
bills we can just retain because we know
there'll be budget just to be done with
it okay so I don't know if we
necessarily need two hours we maybe
could just do 11 and because I think
there's probably five bills we could
retain and then the other four that we
have to work on we will probably need
agency folks in it might be a little bit
longer and I'm not sure I can get them
in on this quick of a turnaround
we have dot at one o'clock in the
afternoon
Tuesday so
okay okay I'll see what I can schedule I
think Janet's deadline for the calendar
is at three today so I'm gonna I'll see
who I can Wrangle up but just the Cloudy
fight we meet tomorrow
yes but we do not meet on Friday
and we do not meet on Monday next week
so oh I forgot it's a legal holiday but
we have Thursday and then Tuesday or the
next two days when we meet I'm just
trying to balance my schedule and and
Wednesday is held for a possible session
day
and we were still told to hold that so I
don't think by the time I find out if
there is a session we probably wouldn't
really be able to use that day anyways
so I think next week will only be
Tuesday and the following week we'll do
uh build work sessions on these bills
that we get referred and that's the
other thing so next next week on the
floor we're likely going to get way more
bills from because education is exacting
a lot today and tomorrow
so we're gonna doing House Bill one and
two will be a lot of work and then when
you factor in possibly up to like 20
separate bills you know that you know we
made to consider so but we'll keep track
he has yeah we had a chat this morning
and
possibly 10 if yeah if I can if I can
get an agency it'd really be doe if I if
their folks can come talk about a couple
of these other bills maybe we'll try to
foreign
well you know what I'd rather give your